my name is Martha May Salatin I'm
married to Eric salad town I'm from
Iliamna Alaska was born and raised here
I enjoy hunting fishing camping anything
that has to do with the outdoors
beautiful day to go play on the lake see
if I can't find some birds Eric left
early this morning with a fishing client
so I got the rest of the day to go out
and motor around on the lake I'm gonna
first check out this little pond that's
not too far away from here Eric and I
have hunted over there and been
successful before so I figured that's a
good place to go hopefully I can prove
to Eric that I'm just a good hunter as
he is Martha and Eric Salatin live on
the Iliamna Peninsula during the summer
months where they hunt and fish to
maintain their subsistence lifestyle
I grew up out here you really learn to
love and hate the lake it's a renewable
resource that you can always depend on
but you also learn that's very dangerous
the largest freshwater lake here in
Alaska 80 miles long by 20 miles wide
and if you get caught up here on an ugly
day winter or summer potentially be
really dangerous this is the first spot
it's a little lake that's right over
here so we're gonna head over there
hopefully there's a bird eggs right
there I'm gonna take a pee got that spot
there see what's on this side you gotta
be a little quiet out here nice to not
spook the birds let them know you're
here
there's one go over there I think
they're good dabbling ducks I'm gonna
walk down behind this brush line here
and see if I can't get my closer
I immediately spotted two ducks there
could be more haven't really taking a
full look
hopefully they'll swim a little bit
closer towards us and I'll be able to
shoot him we'll see what we got here
they're right in front of us
I can't tell how far out but I didn't
shotgun range
sit somewhere cancer we're just a
fishing dock that all tastes very good
on to the next there's certain kinds of
ducks that taste good and certain kinds
of ducks that don't wear cancers are one
of the ones that don't so we're gonna
keep moving see if we can't find
something else came to this lake here
had two birds in it but they're just not
the kind that we want I'm gonna load up
here go over to this island right over
here called rabbit island it's a good
spot couple small little ponds on it
hopefully there's birds over there